Wir wollen blicken auf die 2. Bundesliga der Männer und heute legen wir einen Schwerpunkt auf den HSV, auf den 1. FC Nürnberg, auf Eintracht Braunschweig und das tun wir mit Anna Lautenbach, Fadi Keblavi und mit Nando Silva. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk, das ist das Intro, das ihr schon heiß erwartet.
Und das 1-0.
Bevor wir loslegen, ein Live-Ergebnisservice, der euch lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern gar nichts bringt. 2-0 Schalke. Habt ihr es schon gesehen? 5 Minuten gespielt, Kenan Karaman hat gerade das 2-0 gemacht. Vor allem ohne Zuschauer, da entfaltet dieses Start in seine wahre Pracht. Nando würde wahrscheinlich zustimmen. Also ein etwas anderer, ungeplannter Start in diese Sendung. Aber ihr hört es schon, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir nehmen gerade parallel zum nachgeholtem Spiel, zum verschobenen Spiel, Osnabrück gegen Schalke auf. Und nach 6 Spielminuten kann man sagen, ja, Osnabrück wohl abgestiegen und Schalke 04 drin. Sollten sie mich das Lügen strafen, dann werden wir es vielleicht auch noch live während der Sendung erfahren. Also schön, dass ihr hier seid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und schön, dass ihr drei hier seid. Als Erstes wollen wir mal so allgemein auf diesen Spieltag blicken. Jetzt sind wir quasi schon live eingestiegen mit dem verschobenen Spiel. Nando, vielleicht willst du mal anfangen, jetzt jenseits von allen HSV-Themen, die wir gleich noch besprechen. Was war denn für dich noch wichtig an diesem Spieltag?
Oben an der Tabelle gar nichts, außer dass St. Pauli nicht im Volksparkstadion den Aufstieg gefeiert hat. Und im Grunde schaut man jetzt so mit halbem Auge ein bisschen den Abstiegskampf. Der ist noch sehr, sehr interessant. Aber um sich irgendwie keine Resthoffnung zu machen, versuche ich eigentlich nicht auf die ersten drei zu schauen, auch wenn man da immer noch ein bisschen rechnen kann. Ich gucke eher nach unten, schaue mir da an, wie sich ein paar sympathische und ein paar nicht so sympathische Mannschaften um den Klassenerhalt schlagen.
Möchtest du outcallen, wem du damit meinst oder...
Ich freue mich, wenn Hansa Rostock absteigt.
Da hat natürlich der KSC sein Übriges zu getan.
Und ich finde es ganz cool, wenn der FCK drin bleibt. Irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, mag ich diesen Traditionsverein. Ich würde auch gerne mal zum Betzenberg fahren, zum Auswärtsspiel. Das ist mir bisher noch nicht gelungen und für nächste Saison sieht es ja ganz gut aus.
Ja, also der KSC gewinnt in Rostock mit 2 zu 1, deswegen Rostock Weizherr 17. Und der FCK-Fadi gewinnt mit 4 zu 1 gegen Magdeburg. Hat die Friedheim-Funkle-Magic jetzt doch irgendwie gegriffen? Ich konnte das Spiel nicht sehen, ich habe nur das Ergebnis gesehen.
Ich konnte das Spiel auch nicht sehen, vielleicht ist mir auch egal. Ich gucke leider nur auf den Abstiegskampf. Kaiserslautern nehme ich da inzwischen fast schon raus. Und hier in Nürnberg hoffen alle nur noch auf Niederlagen von Hansa Rostock und dem SV Wien-Wiesbaden, weil die Hoffnung in die eigene Mannschaft nicht mehr vorhanden ist.
Ich sehe schon dieses Einstiegssegment. Es wird immer egoistischer.
Es sind 32 Spiele vorbei, da muss man egoistisch werden irgendwann.
Ja gut, dann ist die Frage, Anna, was war für dich dann wichtig an diesem Spieltag? Auch nur Eintracht Braunschweig?
Ja, einerseits natürlich schon, da aber eingeschoben. Ich bin etwas irritiert, wie sicher ihr den 1. FC Kaiserslautern in der 2. Bundesliga wähnt in der nächsten Saison. Weil der Letzte spielt dagegen die glorreiche Eintracht aus Braunschweig. Also so ganz in trockenen Tüchern sich den FC K, ehrlich gesagt, auch nicht. Vielleicht mit einem besseren Trend insgesamt im Vergleich vor allem zu WN Wiesbaden. Aber auch da ganz egoistisch hoffe ich, dass sie vielleicht am Wochenende und auch eine Woche später noch ein bisschen schwächeln. Ansonsten bin ich immer wieder fasziniert in dieser Phase der Saison, wie kurz vor dem Aufstieg den Aufstiegsaspiranten so ein bisschen die Puste auszugehen scheint.
Kiel gegen Wien, Wiesbaden nur mit Problemen. 1 zu 0 gewonnen über St. Pauli, werden wir gleich sprechen. Nur die Fortuna hatte ein Freispiel, möchte man fast schon sagen. Es ist leider tatsächlich so, ich kann nicht widersprechen. Also gegen den Club, ich meine, da werden wir ja gleich nochmal drüber sprechen. Aber ich hatte auf einem Bildschirm dieses Fortuna-Distituts-Spiel und auf dem anderen das Nordderby. Und das war schon das Hamburg-Derby. Keine Ahnung, wie man es jetzt genauer benennen sollte. Also St. Pauli gegen Hamburg in umgedrehter Reihenfolge. In der zweiten Hälfte hatte zwar der Club mal den Ball, so arg gefährlich war es aber trotzdem nicht. Da fiel die Entscheidung, Fadi, dass du hier in diese Sendung kommen wolltest. Das kann ich sagen, als ich gesehen habe, mit welchem Anlauf der Club da versaut hat.
Vielen Dank, 1.
Danke.
Ich fand dann aber tatsächlich, die Szene des Spieltags war dann doch im anderen Spiel. Und ich fand es leider die peinliche Szene des Spieltags, diese Rudelbildung vor dem Derby in Hamburg. Das war so ein sehr, sehr abgenutztes Männerding irgendwie von beiden Seiten. Ja, also wenn es eine peinliche Situation der Saison gibt, dann ist es in 99 dieser peinlichen Situationen wahrscheinlich der erste Weg zu Nürnberg vertreten. Aber an der Eins stehen jetzt die beiden leider.
Ja, aber die beiden oder muss man da nicht ein bisschen mehr auf St. Pauli zeigen? Also wenn man halt beim Warm-Machen in die HSV-Hälfte ja nicht nur reinläuft, sondern halt auch in die Spieler. Ich meine, also Nando, deine Meinung, glaube ich, wird sehr klar sein. Deswegen erst die von Anna und dann deine. Alles klar. Also, klar, völlig sinnlos, völlig übertrieben. Und es hat ja auch nichts gebracht.
Ja, also ich hatte mich tatsächlich im Zuge dieses Spiels so ein bisschen versucht, ins Verhältnis zu setzen, weil wir ja unseren Derby-Gegner auch in der gleichen Liga haben. Und in der Situation, so die einen gucken vielleicht noch mit einem Viertel Auge nach oben, die anderen könnten in dem Spiel aufsteigen. Find ich, darfst du den Weg halt in die Hälfte einfach nicht machen. Das ist eine unnötige Provokation, dass die Hamburger dann darauf angehen. Hamburger, HSV, also die blau-weißen. Ja, finde ich vorhersehbar. Ist halt so ein bisschen affig. Aber grundsätzlich glaube ich, nicht so überraschend in Anbetracht der Gesamtsituation.
So und jetzt darfst du mit deinem Take kommen. Sorry, dass ich dich eingebremst habe.
Kein Problem. Ich höre mir gerne Meinungen von Außenstehenden zu der Situation an. Denn ich war jetzt auch vorher schon zu Gast in Millantown, zur Spielbesprechung vor dem Spiel und nach dem Spiel. Und auch Michael von Millantown war sich einig. Das ist ein ungeschriebenes Gesetz, das macht man nicht. Man läuft nicht in die Aufwärmübung des Gegners hinein. Also unabhängig davon, dass man vielleicht mal die Mittellinie übertreten kann. Ja, kann ja mal passieren. Aber es gibt ein Video, das zeigt, dass die volle Lotte in die Übung reinsprinten. Da muss man sich nicht wundern, dass bei so einem Spiel, bei den Emotionen, die drin sind, natürlich die provozierte Mannschaft da reagiert. Also bitte, das hat dann, glaube ich, auch nicht viel mit Männern und Frauen zu tun, sondern das ist dann einfach der Emotionalität eines solchen Spiels geschuldet. Und das gehört sich nicht. Man betritt beim Wahrmachen die Hälfte des anderen nicht. Das macht man nicht. Und da würde ich auch sagen, das kann man sich auch mal eingestehen und sich kneifen. Und wenn man als Gast dann ein solches Psychospielchen machen möchte, dann erwartet man, glaube ich, auch diese Reaktion. Ich würde es auch gar nicht so hoch hängen, weil am Ende auf dem Platz war es ja lange nicht so hektisch oder aggressiv, wie es vielleicht in dieser kurzen Sekundensituation war.
Ja, aber gleichzeitig zeigt das ja vielleicht auch, dass was Anna gesagt hat, nämlich, dass den Aufstiegsaspiranten immer so ein bisschen der Stift geht in dieser Saisonphase. Und vielleicht kann man das ja in dieser Szene auch sehen bei St. Pauli. Es war unnötig, es war sehr wahrscheinlich intendiert, damit so eine gewisse Schärfe reinzubringen. Aber auf dem Platz konnten sie es ja nicht umsetzen. Weil es war ja mit all den Irrungen und Wirrungen, die dieses Spiel ging, aberkannter Treffer und so weiter und so fort. Aber war es ja ein verdieter Sieg für den HSV?
Ich finde, dass der HSV das sehr ruhig und sachlich angegangen ist. Unsere Befürchtungen vor dem Spiel waren eher, dass das nicht so der Fall ist. Beide Trainer gehören eher zu dem emotionalen Genre auf der Trainerbank. Also Fabi Hürzler führt, glaube ich, die gelbe Karte-Statistik der Trainer an. Steffen Baumgart ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt ein Mann leiser Töne. Und man konnte schon davon ausgehen, eben aufgrund der Konstellationen, Aufstieg des Stadtrivalen im eigenen Stadion. Oh, will man nicht, dass da eher viel Emotion auf dem Platz ist. Und das war eigentlich überhaupt nicht der Fall. Das war ein sehr nüchternes und sachliches Spiel beider Mannschaften, die sehr diszipliniert gespielt haben, sehr taktisch versucht haben, sich zu neutralisieren. Und irgendwo ein Stück weit, meine ich, gesehen zu haben, dass St. Pauli auch mit dem Unentschieden eigentlich ganz zufrieden war und das 0-0 auch mitgenommen hätte, weil reicht denen. Die können es zu Hause klar machen, ohne Probleme. Und ja, war eher ein gutes Spiel vom HSV, ein normales Spiel von St. Pauli, ohne ihre überragenden Momente, die sie in dieser ganzen Saison schon zuhauf hatten.
Ja, aber hat dich das nicht überrascht, dass die Art und Weise, wie St. Pauli gespielt hat, nicht so ganz zum sonstigen Auftreten gepasst hat? Also Fabian Hürzeler ist ja nun wirklich kein zurückhaltender Mensch, muss man sagen, auch in der Außendarstellung. Dass die Fans natürlich davon träumen, im Volkspark aufzusteigen, auch völlig klar. Aber ich fand, dass man dafür echt wenig gezeigt hat. Und das lag natürlich auch am HSV. Also der HSV hat das sehr gut gemacht. Aber der HSV hatte irrelange Ballbesitzphasen, in denen St. Pauli überhaupt nicht gepresst hat. Und ich hätte mir da viel mehr erwartet, eben auch gemessen an dem, wie man vor diesem Spiel eigentlich da reingegangen ist.
Ja, auf der einen Seite ist auch Fabian Hürzeler ein, wie hat Michael das genannt, ein Defensiv-Fetishist. Also das ist die beste Abwehr der Liga. Die können sich darauf verlassen, dass sie im Zweifel jeden Raum zulaufen und kaum etwas zulassen. Und dann willst du sicherlich auch beim Stadtrivalen nicht ins offene Messer laufen. Und der HSV hat seine Momente im Offensivspiel mit der Qualität auch, können schnell umschalten, insbesondere unter Steffen Baumgart. Da weißt du nicht, wann dieses hohe Pressing losgeht. Und ich glaube, dass Hürzeler da einfach eine Risikoabwägung gemacht hat. Wie viel Vollgas möchte ich gehen und möchte ich vielleicht sogar hier Böse verlieren und auch vielleicht diese schlechte Stimmung, die bei den Fans ja dann aufgekommen ist, aufgrund dieses Traumes im Volkspark aufzusteigen. Will ich das richtig riskieren oder wege ich einfach ab und nehme es im nächsten Heimspiel mit vor unseren Fans, vor unserer Kulisse, wo wir komplett eskalieren können? Und ich glaube, es war am Ende eine Risikoabwägung von Hürzeler. Sicherlich auch, weil der HSV nicht so gespielt hat, wie man es vielleicht auch von Steffen Baumgart gewohnt ist. Er hat nicht dieses intensive Pressing, was er gerne spielen lässt, von vorne rein voll drauf anlaufen, mit fünf, sechs Mann schon in der gegierischen Hälfte zuzustellen. Das hat er auch kaum gemacht. Er hat deutlich mehr variiert. Dann hat er die defensiven Flügel stark besetzt, um eben Hartl und Afoulaian nicht ins Spiel kommen zu lassen. Insbesondere Hartl Reis ist nicht aus der rechtsverteidiger Position ins Zentrum gerückt, was er sonst immer tut und wir dann über eine Dreierkette aufbauen. Sondern der ist defensiv auf der rechten Verteidigerposition geblieben und war immer bei Hartl in der ersten Hälfte. Und man hat einfach Dom P in der Defensivbewegung vom Flügel weggenommen, nach innen als zweiten Stürmer und dafür Poreba als gelernten Sechser die linke Seite neben Muhheim verteidigen lassen und damit einen ganz anderen defensiven Block aufgestellt, mit dem St. Pauli, glaube ich, nicht gerechnet hat. Weil Dom P ist nicht der defensiv Stärkste und mit dem Van der Bremt als rechten Verteidiger, der sehr offensiv orientiert denkt, hätte man Hartl auch viel mehr Platz gelassen. Und nachdem man aus dieser defensiveren Aufstellung und taktischen Idee dann es geschafft hat, dieses Umschaltspiel von St. Pauli auch rauszunehmen und den auch gar keine Standards zuzulassen, wo Hartl eben sehr, sehr stark ist und die Mannschaft insgesamt auch gut trifft, hat man da schon ein paar Stärken von St. Pauli so eingrenzen können und deswegen brauchte das Spiel, glaube ich, auch so 20 Minuten, um überhaupt in Fahrt zu kommen, weil sich das erstmal einsortieren musste.
Und dann war es aber gut in Fahrt, inklusive des Treffers von Robert Glatze, der zurückgenommen wurde. Ich bitte um kurze Abstimmung per Handzeichen. Wer fand, dass dieser Treffer zurecht zurückgenommen wurde? Ja, da traut sich jetzt keiner. Und was ist, wenn ich euch sage, in der Laufbewegung trifft Glatze mit seinem linken Schienbein den Fuß von Saliakis, der durch diesen Kontakt zu Fall kommt. Der Schiedsrichter hat diesen Ablauf auf dem Feld genauso wahrgenommen und den Kontakt als V-Spiel bewertet. Ändert sich dann eure Meinung? Nichts ist passiert, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen. Muss man froh sein, Nando, dass der HSV dieses Spiel anders gewonnen hat und die sowieso schon laute Diskussionen dadurch nicht noch lauter geworden ist, oder?
Ich denke schon. Also so ein Tor zurückzunehmen ist schon für mich skandalös. Aber wenn du das Spiel dann deswegen vielleicht verlierst, weil so ein Tor gibt in der 24. Minute auch dem Spiel eine ganz andere Dynamik. Jetzt triffst du kurz vor Ende durch eine Standardsituation. Aber bei so einem ausgeglichenen Spiel, wo viel auf dem Spiel auch steht, das wäre schwierig geworden. Ich glaube, die Diskussion ist eh schon groß rund um VAR-Einsätze, Eingriffsmöglichkeiten oder wie sie eingreifen und was die Schiedsrichter überhaupt noch trauen, selbst zu entscheiden. Das wäre nicht besser geworden. Zumal wir, glaube ich, in der ersten Liga dann bei Stuttgart gegen Bayern eine ähnliche Situation hatten, die dann zum Elfmeter führte. Also das sind ja keine Einzelfälle.
Von demselben VAR muss man dazu sagen. Von Benjamin Brandt war der Schiedsrichter auf dem Feld, der eben diese Streifbewegung erkannt hat. Und Benjamin Brandt war derjenige, der gesagt hat, das reicht mir, um dich nicht rauszuschicken. So wie dann später im Spiel Stuttgart gegen Bayern der Schiedsrichter auf dem Feld, Tobias Welz, erkannt hat, dass Serge Nabry den Finger ins Auge bekommt von Wademar Anton. Und Benjamin Brandt wieder gesagt hat, ja das reicht mir, das guckst du dir nicht nochmal wieder an. Das lieber den Strafschluss schnell ausführen. Ja, also gut, das wurde ausreichend thematisiert. Und natürlich gibt es auch immer Dinge, über die man sich aufregen kann. Und das hat auf jeden Fall dazu gehört, die Spieleitung war nicht dem Spiel angemessen. Ich glaube, so kann man es dann doch formulieren. Die Frage ist, was machen wir jetzt daraus Nando? Also es sind 4 Punkte Rückstand auf Fortuna Düsseldorf. Bei noch 6 zu vergebenen Punkten ist das natürlich ein bisschen viel. Auf der anderen Seite spielt aber Düsseldorf jetzt in Kiel. Und was, mein lieber Nando, passiert, wenn dort Kiel sich vielleicht die Meisterschaft holt, indem man eben gewinnt und der HSV am Tag vorher, am Freitag, sein Spiel in Paderborn gewonnen hat?
Dann geht es mir am nächsten Wochenende sehr, sehr schlecht und ich bin sehr, sehr aufgeregt, wie glaube ich die gesamte HSV-Fangemeinde. Klar, das ist das, was im Hinterkopf ist. Was passiert, wenn? Aber grundsätzlich sollte sich insgesamt für den HSV aufgrund der Saison eigentlich nicht viel an der Bewertung ändern, weil gut ist es trotzdem nicht. Nur, weil wir am Ende vielleicht die Chance haben, Dritter zu werden und das vielleicht mal andere ausrutschen und nicht wir in der 97. Minute irgendwie den Ausstieg wieder aus der Hand gerissen bekommen, sollte man schon hier jetzt schon bei den Verantwortlichen auch im Sommer eine knallharte Analyse fahren, warum es erneut nicht gereicht hat. Und da darf auch ein Sieg gegen St. Pauli im Derby und eine Stadtmeisterschaft nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen, dass wir sportlich hier nicht das abliefern, was wir abliefern müssten mit dem Kader und mit dem Potenzial, den auch dieses Stadion zu Hause und die gesamte Fangemeinschaft mit sich bringt. Ich glaube, der Support ist ziemlich überragend für einen Verein, der eigentlich längst hätte aufsteigen wollen und trotzdem kriegt er wahrscheinlich dieses Jahr sogar einen Zuschauerekord hin, den es nicht mal in der ersten Liga gab, obwohl die Preise gestiegen sind und alles teurer geworden ist. Das ist schon irre. Und da muss man sich auch mal die Frage stellen bei den Verantwortlichen, wie kriegen wir da eigentlich mal diese gesamte Kraft auch mal wirklich über eine gesamte Saison konstant auf die Straße, auch wenn es viele Faktoren gibt, die immer unglücklich sind. Aber das muss man irgendwann auch mal abschütteln können. Und das ist das, was mich so ein bisschen ambivalent auf die Situation schauen lässt. Ich freue mich über den Sieg. Das tut gut. Auf der anderen Seite möchte ich mich nicht zu sehr freuen, weil die Saison einfach zu viele Fragen aufwirft.
Welche Fragen denn? Also gehört zu diesen Fragen auch die Trainerposition oder haben wir da die Antwort, nämlich Steffen Baumgart?
Nein, für mich gehört sowohl der Sportvorstand, das gesamte Drumherum, die Leistungskultur innerhalb des Profibereichs und natürlich auch der Trainer dazu. Weil so, wie der Trainer bei uns angetreten ist, Steffen Baumgart mit seinen klaren Worten an in der Antrittspk und den Schwierigkeiten, die er hatte, zur Mannschaft oder mit der Mannschaft zusammen zu finden, muss man sich da auch die Frage stellen, passt der Trainer eigentlich zu der Spielidee, die der HSV verkörpern möchte, zu den Spielern, die wir im Kader haben? Müssen wir für den Trainer den gesamten Kader umbauen? Wollen wir das, wollen wir das mit Jonas Boldt, wollen wir das komplett neu machen? Da muss man schon diverses in Frage stellen und natürlich auch schauen, welche Spieler verlassen den Verein, möchten das oder müssen den Verein aus finanziellen Gründen verlassen. Auch die ganzen Fragen sind… das sind so viele. Und dass der Aufsichtsrat sich noch nicht sicher ist, was er auf der Sportvorstandsposition macht, die natürlich dann entscheidet, was mit dem Trainer passiert, das sehe ich halt kritisch. Und das ist eben die andere Seite neben der Freude vom Freitagabend.
Ja, aber wenn ich mir jetzt mal die jüngeren Ergebnisse angucke, dann sehe ich klar ein 0 zu 1, aber gegen Heustern Kiel zu Hause. Ich sehe ein 4 zu 0 bei Braunschweig, Anna wird sich nicht so sehr gerne dran erinnern. Und jetzt dieses 1 zu 0 gegen St. Pauli, also könnte man nicht auch sagen, vielleicht haben ja Team und Trainer jetzt zusammengefunden. Und klar wünscht man sich in der idealen Welt, dass das sofort passiert, aber das ist ja eigentlich nicht erwartbar. Das ist die Ausnahme von der Regel.
Das ist vollkommen richtig, was du sagst. Und natürlich waren die letzten beiden Spiele gegen Braunschweig eine formstarke Mannschaft unter Scherning, die sich super rausgekämpft hat und echt tolle Ergebnisse erzielt hat. Und im Derby, das waren schon zwei Spiele, wo man sagen kann, ja, okay, das war gut, das war auch vernünftig gespielt, taktisch sauber eingestellt, aber davor eben nicht. Und ich tue mich halt schwer, weil ich momentan noch nicht erkennen kann, welche Spielidee Steffen Baumgart wirklich implementieren möchte. Und ob seine Spielidee des hohen Anlaufens und des riskanten Umschaltspiels und eben auch der Idee, die Defensive eher etwas zu vernachlässigen, auch wenn es jetzt in den letzten beiden Spielen gut aussah. Er spielt im Gegensatz zu seinem Vorgänger immerhin mit Reis und Schonlau gesund. Und auch da dauerte es lang, bis sich da alles stabilisiert hatte. Ich kann das noch nicht, ich mag momentan noch nicht sagen, dass der Trend beim HSV passt. Dafür ist man da noch ein bisschen zu sehr leid geplagt in den letzten Jahren. Und Steffen Baumgart hat sehr, ja, mit 100 Prozent eigentlich angefangen. Der ist voll reingegangen, auch mit seinen Aussagen. Ich weiß nicht, wo da die Steigerung oder der Turnaround noch möglich ist, dass sich das anpasst und was dafür passieren muss. Und ich glaube schon, dass man erst mal die beiden Spiele jetzt noch unabhängig vom finalen Tabellenstand abwarten muss. Um dann auch wirklich bewerten zu können, können wir mit Steffen Baumgart und der einen oder anderen Anpassung eine vernünftige Saison spielen, bei der man auch mal das sportliche Ziel erreicht.
Also Paderborn auswärts und der Club zu Hause, das sind die nächsten beiden Partien für den HSV. Jetzt müsste ja aber diese Bewertung der Saison und dann ja auch eine daran hängende Trainerentscheidung vom Sportvorstand kommen, den du ja auch schon mit aufgezählt hast bei deiner Liste. Gleichzeitig wissen wir, wir haben jetzt das Frühjahr, das fortgeschrittene Frühjahr. Man weiß zwar noch nicht, für welche Liga man plant, aber sehr wahrscheinlich ist es die zweite und sollte da auch schon relativ weit sein. Also wie sehr wackelt auch der Stuhl von Jonas Boldt und was wäre deine persönliche Meinung dazu?
Ich glaube, es ist aktuell 50-50, was man so aus dem Aufsichtsrat hört, der ja manchmal sehr mitteilungsfreudig ist hier in Hamburg. Grundsätzlich stelle ich mir halt die Frage, inwieweit der sportliche Misserfolg, also das Verfehlen des sportlichen Zieles, irgendwann dazu führen muss, dass ein von mir geschätzter Jonas Boldt, der sehr sachlich, sehr ruhig und sehr gewissenhaft den Verein auch wieder finanziell mit auf die Beine gestellt hat, unter auch sehr, sehr schwierigen Bedingungen, sei es ein Vuskovich, sei es Corona, hat er sehr ruhig und sachlich und mit doch größtenteils guten Transfers und Transferüberschuss mit dafür Sorge getragen, dass wir finanziell etwas besser dastehen und hat nicht mehr nur nach Namen eingekauft, sondern nach dem Spieler, der auch ins System und zum Trainer passt. Das bewerte ich sehr positiv. Aber dennoch, unter Jonas Boldt und seiner ruhigen Art fehlt vielleicht ein Stück weit doch Leistungskultur, Leistungsprinzipien, weil die Mannschaft einfach nicht konstant die PS auf die Straße bringt und man sagt es ja immer, das wird von der Führung vorgelebt. Und ja, da muss man Jonas Boldt hinterfragen und so sehr ich ihn als unseren Vorstand in der Öffentlichkeit und auch in seiner Arbeit schätze, wenn man da einen guten und auch vernünftig denkenden alternativen Menschen hat, der das wirtschaftlich und sportlich ruhig weiterführen kann, vielleicht mit etwas mehr Elan, aber dennoch mit Augenmaß auch bei Transfers, dann kann ich mir auch diesen Kulturwechsel nach den Jahren jetzt vorstellen, ja.
Ja, aber hat man den? Also, Hassan Sadihamidzic, Dieter Hecking haben beide Zeit.
Dieter Hecking hatten wir schon als Trainer. Das war damals super, aber danke nein. Als Sportvorstand finde ich seine Arbeit nicht ganz so gut, aber da kann Fadi bestimmt noch ein bisschen mehr zu erzählen. Hassan, weiß ich nicht, ob der in so einem kleinen Club, ich habe das bei Bayern schon nicht ganz verstanden.
Kleiner Club, ich bitte dich.
In der 2. Liga vom FC Bayern mit unbegrenzten Möglichkeiten, weiß ich nicht. Ja, es ist schwierig. Manchmal zaubert man jemanden auch aus einer unteren Liga. Nein, danke Max, es reicht jetzt mit dem Namen.
Ich will dir doch einfach nur klarmachen, dass auch eine Gefahr darin steht, jetzt in das Beutel zu ersetzen.
Diese Gefahr sehe ich allerdings auch, weil die jetzt drei genannten Namen aus meiner Sicht definitiv nicht besser werden. Ich denke auch, der Markt ist nicht so groß. Auch damals war Jonas Beutler eher jemand, den man aus der zweiten Reihe geholt hat bei Leverkusen. Wenn man dieses Glück noch mal hat, okay. Aber Felix Magath, Dieter Hecking, Hasan Salihamidjic sind jetzt nicht unbedingt die Namen, von denen ich glaube, dass die beim HSV diese gute Basis, die gelegt wurde, weiterführen können.
Und wenn du tippen müsstest, oder du musst jetzt tippen.
Okay, ich muss.
Trainer und im Sportvorstand. Müssen sie beide gehen? Muss nur einer von beiden gehen? Was denkst du, wird im Sommer passieren?
Also entweder beide oder keiner. Dann lieber beide behalten. Wenn ich die Alternativen bedenke, die so im Raume stehen, dann lieber beide behalten als zwei neue. Weil ich glaube nicht, dass der Sportvorstand mitgehen kann, ohne dass Steffen Baumgart dann vielleicht auch Opfer des neuen Sportvorstandes wird. Das glaube ich nicht.
Okay, wir werden es beobachten. Jetzt erstmal werden wir schauen, was am nächsten Spieltag passiert. Erst mal auswärts in Paderborn die sogenannten Hausaufgaben erledigen und dann das Topspiel angucken. Und wer hätte das gedacht? Heuchtern Kiel die Daumen drücken. Und zwar so richtig dolle. Aber gut, das sind eben die Wolten, die so eine Zweitligasaison beschreibt. Und zu diesen Wolten gehört offenbar auch Fadi, dass man sich zwei Spieltage vor Schluss von seinem... Welche Funktion hatte Dieter Hecking? Sportgeschäftsführer, Sportvorstand?
Sportvorstand. Mir ging das gerade ein bisschen zu schnell. Dieses Dieter Hecking zurück zum HSV, das wurde mir jetzt zu sehr. Der hat in Nürnberg noch einen Vertrag bis Ende 2025. Der FC Nürnberg hat kein Geld, also genau.
Wir zahlen keine Ablöse mehr für solche Leute.
Ich glaube, der Klub würde euch bei der Ablöse entgegenkommen.
Ich muss das dankend ablehnen aus dem hohen Norden.
Schade.
Aber Fadi, warum tut man das? Warum trennt man sich zwei Spieltage vor Schluss von einem Sportvorstand?
Panik, wie eigentlich die hinter fast allen Handlungen beim 1. FC Nürnberg steht. Es gab von Beginn an Diskussionen in Nürnberg, ob Dieter Hecking als Sportvorstand der Richtige ist, weil er eben ein guter Trainer war. Das heißt nicht, dass er automatisch ein guter Sportvorstand ist. Ich war da von Beginn an sehr skeptisch. Und dieses Skepsis hat sich jetzt wohl bis in den Verein hinein ausgebreitet. Und dann kamen noch ein paar unglückliche Auftritte von Dieter Hecking in dieser Saison dazu. Er hat Demonstrationen gegen rechts auf einer Podiumsdiskussion als Folklore bezeichnet. Er war vor dem Spiel gegen den KSC vor kurzem. Hat er in der Trainingswoche zuvor. Er hat zur Mannschaft gesprochen, was bei der Mannschaft da schon nicht gut ankam. Er hat die Führungsspieler aufgefordert. Vor allem die erfahrenen Spieler, die jetzt vorangehen müssen. In Nürnberg sitzen diese erfahrenen Spieler. Aber seit Saisonbeginn sind alle auf der Bank. Das muss da schon wieder Worte gegeben werden. Dann ist er in der Halbzeitpause des Spiels gegen den KSC wieder in die Kabine unabgesprochen. Mit dem Trainer, der darüber auch sehr überrascht war. Er muss da auch noch mal ordentlich Dampf abgelassen haben. All das gemeinsam mit der sportlich vollkommen unbefriedigenden Situation seit vier Jahren hat dann dazu geführt, dass man sich anscheinend schon vor dem Spiel in Düsseldorf im Aufsichtsrat, der auch in einer neuen Zusammensetzung ist seit dem vergangenen Herbst, mit mehr Hacking-Skeptikern im Aufsichtsrat, dass man sich entschieden hat, das jetzt dann mal doch zu beenden.
Okay, das heißt, es gab gute Gründe? Auch wenn ich Panik als Grund infrage stellen würde, ob das so ein guter Ratgeber ist. Und du bewertest es dann dementsprechend auch als richtigen Schritt. Habe ich das richtig durchgehört?
Ja, tatsächlich. Also, man muss ein bisschen ausholen, Dieter Hecking ist 2020 nach Nürnberg gekommen, als dieser beinahe Absturz in die in die dritte Liga passiert ist mit dem Relegationsspiel in Ingolstadt. 96. Minute, Robert Pallikuccia, der Sportvorstand damals, musste gehen. Und dann sollte Dieter Hecking diesen Verein, der auch damals sich in Panik befunden hat und in größter Aufgeregtheit, er sollte ihn befrieden. Das war so ein Argument dafür. Der Name Dieter Hecking kommt zurück nach Nürnberg, der ja als Trainer in Nürnberg tatsächlich gut gearbeitet hat und soll jetzt mal Ruhe reinbringen in diesen Verein. Das ist ihm teilweise gelungen, aber auch nur ein, zwei Jahre lang. Und dass er eine sportliche Strategie entwickeln kann, das habe ich damals schon angezweifelt und das bestätigt sich jetzt. Wenn man auf seine Trainer-Verpflichtungen guckt, Robert Claus, dann kam Markus Weinshill, dann kam Dieter Hecking selbst als Trainer, dann kam Christian Fjell, das sind mindestens drei vollkommen unterschiedliche Trainertypen mit unterschiedlichen Herangehensweisen an dieses Spiel. Robert Claus eher diese Red Bull-Schule, Markus Weinshill gar keine Schule und Christian Fjell, der den spielerischen Ansatz in den Vordergrund stellt. Und dazu wurden dann sehr viele Spieler verpflichtet, die nicht zu den jeweiligen Trainern gepasst haben. Also es war wirklich erfolgerichtig, dass jetzt die Trennung stattfindet, auch wenn es zwei Spiegel vor Saisonende ist.
Okay, gut. Also er hat viel probiert und wenig hat funktioniert. Und gleichzeitig ist die Panik ja logischerweise auch sportlich begründet. Also sechs der letzten sieben Spiele hat man verloren. Man war in fünf der letzten sieben Spielen, hat man kein Tor erzielt. Man hat jetzt noch einen Polster von fünf Punkten Vorsprung auf den Wiesbaden. Für wie groß denkst du oder hältst du die Abstiegsgefahr für den Club?
Tatsächlich groß. Die Mehrheit der Menschen in Nürnberg schaut tatsächlich nur noch auf die Ergebnisse der Konkurrenzweise der eigenen Mannschaft. Mehr oder weniger keinen Punkt mehr zutrauen bis zum Saisonende. Das ist der Mut in Nürnberg. Der 1. FC Nürnberg ist der 1. FC Nürnberg der Klubschaft, die absurdesten Abstiege. Deshalb ist die Skepsis relativ groß in Nürnberg. Aber mit Blick auf die Konkurrenz könnte es dann vielleicht doch noch gut gehen.
Wen Wiesbaden spielt noch in Braunschweig, dann zu Hause gegen St. Pauli. Müssten beide diese Spiele gewinnen, um vorbeizukommen. Für Rostock sieht es noch schwieriger aus, auf Schalke und dann zu Hause gegen Paderborn. Ich meine, klar, kann beides passieren. Ich meine, ich kenne ja auch das Clubumfeld. Ich komme ja aus der Ecke, erst Mittelfranken, dann Unterfranken. Für alle jenseits von Bayern macht das überhaupt keinen Unterschied. Für alle Franken macht das einen riesigen Unterschied. Das ist nämlich der Unterschied zwischen Bier und Weinfranken. Eins von beiden noch viel, viel lieber. Das ist ein großer Unterschied, ich kann es euch sagen. Aber ich will jetzt nicht so sehr reingehen, dass es vielleicht dann auch folglore. Deswegen kenne ich schon den Gemütszustand von Klubberern. Trotzdem erlaube ich mir jetzt einfach mal die Ferndiagnose. Selbst der Klub würde es nicht schaffen, in dieser Situation noch abzusteigen.
Tatsächlich war die Stimmungslage in dieser Saison ja schon mal erstaunlich positiv. Also so die ersten Spiele unter Christian Fjell, da sah das auch, wenn es Niederlagen gab, sah das sehr oft sehr ansehnlich aus, vor allem mit Blick auf das letzte Jahr, wo man ja erst am letzten Spieltag sich in Paderborn mit diesem Sieg vor dem Abstieg gerettet hat. Und da war der Klub plötzlich mal wieder positives Stadtgespräch. Also es war tatsächlich so, dass viele Leute sich gefreut haben, wie attraktiv Christian Pfehl zumindest zu spielen versucht. Und es hat auch sehr lange geklappt. Und irgendwann kam dann eben dieser Cut, den sich in Nürnberg keiner so richtig erklären kann.
Was ja auch dann eben ein Schlaglicht auf Christian Pfehl selbst wirft, um den es ja auch noch interessante Gerüchte gibt. Hertha BSC wird da immer wieder genannt, was auch interessant ist, weil er überzeugt jetzt gerade nicht durch Ergebnisse in der aktuellen Phase. Wie groß ist denn seine Verantwortung jetzt für die aktuelle Krise des Clubs?
Das ist tatsächlich die große Frage. Lange Zeit war Christian Pfehl so außerhalb jeglicher Kritik durch diese Serie. Jetzt gibt es auch wieder viele, die sagen, eigentlich hätte erster Trainer gehen müssen und dann der Sportvorstand. Ich sehe das immer noch ein bisschen anders, eben weil ich glaube, dass Dieter Hecking und sein Sportdirektor Olaf Rebbe nicht die Spieler verpflichtet haben oder nicht ausreichend Spieler verpflichtet haben, die zu Christian Pfehls Ballbesitzfußball passen. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass Christian Pfehl die Mannschaften ein Stück weit verloren hat, was daran liegt, dass die älteren Spieler eben gar keine Rolle mehr spielen und wissen, dass sie bei ihm auch keine Rolle mehr spielen werden. Dann gibt es ein paar dieser jungen Spieler wie Can Uson oder Nathaniel Brown, die wissen, sie spielen nächstes Jahr erste Liga auf jeden Fall. Ja, es ist wirklich eine komplizierte Situation für Christian Pfehl. Trotzdem würde ich im Moment noch sagen, man kann mit ihm in die nächste Saison gehen, wenn der neue Sportvorstand, die neue Sportvorständin, ihm die richtigen Spieler zur Verfügung stellt.
Ich fand das interessant zu sehen im Spiel gegen Düsseldorf in der ersten Hälfte, wo Düsseldorf den Ball hatte und tief in der gegnerischen Hälfte stand. Da hast du gesehen, Verteidigen ist gerade nicht so das vom Club, das funktioniert nicht so doll. In der zweiten Hälfte dann, Henne Eifrager natürlich, lag es an Düsseldorf, lag es am Club, aber das Ergebnis war in jedem Fall, der Club hatte den Ball. Und da hast du gemerkt, wie wohl sich die viele der Spieler mit Ball am Fuß fühlen. Als jemand, der nicht so viele Club-Spiele sieht, war ich davon durchaus noch überrascht. Auch wenn ich schon wusste, ich habe mir selber hier zugehört, wenn ich mit Gästen gesprochen habe. Oder ich habe den Gästen zugehört, ich wusste schon, dass es besser geworden ist. Aber das ist schon zu erkennen gewesen, dass es da einen Wandel gibt. Wie würdest du denn die Strategie des Clubs jetzt dann bewerten? Weil das scheint mir ja eine fundamentale Frage zu sein, für welchen Spielsteam man sich jetzt eigentlich entscheidet. Und das, was Christian Fjell da macht, ist ja etwas, was nicht nur sportlich funktionieren kann, nicht muss, aber auch wirtschaftliche Konsequenzen hat. Ich kenne viele Vereine, die würden sagen, ältere Spieler aussortieren, dafür Junge spielen lassen. Und halt halbwegs seine sportlichen Ziele erreichen und ein paar teuer verkaufen zu können, ist doch super.
Also, wie gesagt, am Anfang des Jahres hat alles relativ gut funktioniert, es war ein bisschen Euphorie in der Stadt. Und dann ist auch Christian Fjell so ein bisschen von diesem Ansatz abgekommen, hat öfter mal 1-0-Sieg in Elbersberg, da hat der Club praktisch 90 Minuten verteidigt. Vor Kurzem in Magdeburg auch wieder ein 1-0-Sieg, aber auch wieder überhaupt nicht so, wie man sich Christian Fjell Fußball vorstellt. Also er ist schon eher abgerückt mitunter von seiner Idee. Weiß man jetzt nicht, ob aus Pragmatismus oder weil Dieter Hecking im Hintergrund, wie man in der letzten Saison gesehen hat, ein möglicher Trainer-Nachfolger sein kann. Ja, schwierig. Zumindest an vielen Schuld in Nürnberg, tatsächlich. Auch die Zerrissenheit innerhalb des Vereins. Man hört ja auch dann in solchen Krisen immer sehr viel aus dem Verein heraus. Und man hat schon in den letzten Wochen und Monaten so eine Absetzbewegung von Dieter Hecking wahrnehmen können, wenn man ein bisschen genauer rein gehört.
Aber wo sollte denn der Club eigentlich stehen, wenn ich mir einen Verein anschaue, der 60 Gegentore kassiert hat in 37 Spielen und damit hat man die drittschlechteste Defensive dieser Liga, dann würde ich sagen, mit Rang 13 ist man doch eigentlich relativ fair bewertet.
Damit ist man fair bewertet, glaube ich. Ich glaube, der Verein muss sich jetzt grundsätzlich mal Gedanken machen und das hat eben Dieter Hecking in vier Jahren nicht geschafft, für welche Idee man stehen will und das wird einfach die Aufgabe seines Nachfolgers, seiner Nachfolgerin und in Nürnberg sind die Ansprüche inzwischen wirklich des Publikums äußerst gering nach den letzten Jahren und es akzeptieren, glaube ich, auch in Nürnberg alle, dass der 1. FC Nürnberg inzwischen nur noch ein mittelmäßiger Zweitligist ist, maximal, aber es wünschen sich alle, dass da jemand kommt und eine Idee vermittelt, wie es wieder nach oben gehen kann und am Anfang der Saison hatte man den Eindruck, dass Christian Fjell als Trainer sein kann und jetzt müsste man noch einen Sportvorstand, eine Sportvorständin finden, die einen ähnlichen Enthusiasmus vermittelt. Und das hat Dieter Hecking einfach in den letzten Monaten nicht mehr geschafft.
Und wie weit glaubst du, ist man da bei der Suche nach einem neuen Sportvorstand oder einer neuen Sportvorständin? Denn überraschen kam ja die Trennung von Hecking jetzt nicht.
Überraschen kam sie nicht. Die Vergangenheit lehrt, dass es beim 1. FC Nürnberg immer ein bisschen länger dauern kann. Das liegt auch an der Konstruktion mit einem Aufsichtsrat aus Ehrenamtlichen. Der Sprechervorsitzende des Aufsichtsrats, Peter Mayer, ist Vorstand beim Hauptsponsor und hat da eigentlich genug zu tun im richtigen Leben. Angeblich gibt es schon Kandidaten, wurden schon Gespräche geführt.
Du willst den Namen jetzt nicht nennen, weil du Angst hast, dass Nando sie weiterfunkt an den HSV.
So wie das in Nürnberg klingt, ist das bei uns auch. Nein, danke, ich glaube, das braucht uns nicht.
Es war tatsächlich relativ schnell in der Diskussion, waren dann so Namen, wie man sie immer hört, wenn solche Diskussionen geführt werden. Stefan Reuter, Alain Sutter, beide mit Nürnberger Vergangenheit. Dann hieß es aus dem Aufsichtsrat wieder, die auf keinen Fall mehr, das wäre Ihnen zu sehr, Dieter Hecking 2.0 sozusagen. Es würde wohl eher ein Kandidat werden, der noch nicht so den ganz großen Namen hat. Es war jetzt in den letzten Tagen im Gespräch Joti Caccia-Lexu, glaube ich. Ja, Lexu, genau, 20 Jahre beim Deutschen Fußballbund. Gegen den spricht 20 Jahre beim Deutschen Fußballbund und noch nicht in der Vereinsarbeit tätig. Mein Außenseiter-Tipp ist aber, glaube ich, in Nürnberg schwierig durchzusetzen. Er arbeitet schon im Verein, heißt Osman Cankaya und hat die Fußballerinnen des 1. Elfzehnen in Nürnberg innerhalb sehr kurzer Zeit und mit einem sehr modernen Konzept aus der 3. in die 1. Liga geführt. Sie steigen jetzt zwar wieder ab, aber da, in dieser Abteilung, wird es so gearbeitet, wie man es sich eigentlich von einem modernen Fußballverein wünschen würde. Mit Trainer unabhängiger Spielidee, also der Trainer wird eher zur Spielidee passend verpflichtet. Datenscouting mit Florian Zenger, der hier auch schon mit Untermalen Auftritt hatte. Das wäre eine mutige Entscheidung, aber ich glaube, da gibt es in Nürnberg zu viele Menschen, die dann sagen, Ossmann Schankeier ist zu jung, Ossmann Schankeier hat nur bei den Frauen gearbeitet. Ich glaube, da ist einfach noch zu viel Traditionalismus unterwegs. Auch wenn die Frauen jetzt wieder absteigen aus der ersten Liga, aber das ist mit den Budgetdifferenzen zu den anderen Mannschaften einfach sehr leicht zu erklären. Da wird gut gearbeitet im Verein. Ich glaube, es wird im Verein schon auch gesehen, aber ob das dann ausreicht, dass ein junger Mensch Sportvorstand wird, ohne vorher selbst Fußballer in den Profiligen gewesen zu sein, bezweifle ich noch. Aber das wäre eine mutige Entscheidung für den 1. Und ich glaube, kein besonders großes Risiko, warum soll jemand, der als Polizist und als Trainer gearbeitet hat, ein besserer Sportvorstand sein, als jemand, der seit Jahren genau diesen Job macht, aber halt im Fußball der Frauen.
Ich meine, es wäre schade für die Frauen, wer sich da für die aktuelle Situation interessiert. Da habe ich ja erst gestern Abend eine Sendung zu aufgenommen, zum letzten Spieltag, an dem jetzt ja auch der Abstieg noch nicht rechnerisch komplett besiegelt ist, aber im Grunde eigentlich schon. Ich meine, wenn man sich das anguckt, was er da aufgebaut hat, das war definitiv bemerkenswert, so wie du es gesagt hast. Was dann so Öffentlichkeitsdarstellungen angeht, was in der Saison geprägt von der Schiri-Diskussion, die in einer Art und Weise vom Zaun gebrochen wurde, die nicht so ganz dem Objekt, dem Thema angemessen war, und vor allem die Schiedsrichterinnen in eine ganz schlechte Position gebracht hat. Da hat er auch nicht den Rückwärtsgang eingelegt. Er hat dann auch nicht drei Tage später gesagt, so habe ich es ja gar nicht gemeint. Sondern der Club ist da auf dem Gastpedal geblieben. Dann wurde auf einmal die 6-Sekunden-Regel eingehalten bei Torhüterinnen des Clubs, wenn sie den Ball nicht schnell genug weggeworfen haben. Sehr interessant.
Wobei man da auch sagen muss, er hat seine Meinung öffentlich kundgetan. Ich glaube, er hat es auch relativ gut begründet. Es waren dann alle sehr erschrocken beim DFB, bei den Schiedsrichterinnen. Aber eben dass er dann auch nicht zurückzieht, finde ich, ist dann auch wieder ein positiver Aspekt. Weil er natürlich auch weiß, dass er sich mit der Kritik erst mal Angriffen aussetzt. Und tatsächlich, glaube ich, man müsste sich um die Frauen nicht sorgen, weil auch in der Abteilung die Nachfolge dann relativ gut geregelt werden könnte. Aber er ist meinungsstark und hat da keine Angst vor Diskussionen.
So würde ich es mal nennen. Das glaube ich auch. Dann habe ich auch an dich zwei abschließende Fragen. Die eine Frage bezieht sich auf den Nachwuchs. Wir alle haben von Canuzo gehört. Wir alle sehen, wohin sein Weg führt. Und wohin er noch führen wird, da kann man sehr gespannt sein. Insgesamt steht er stellvertretend für eine etwas bessere Nachwuchsarbeit bzw. durchlässigere Nachwuchsarbeit nach oben hin. So muss man es ja eigentlich formulieren. Wie sie vorher war, kann ich von außen jetzt nicht beurteilen. Wird da noch mehr kommen? Ist das etwas, was immer wieder ein Basisfundament sein könnte für den Club? Oder haben wir es hier mit einer goldenen Generation zu tun?
Ich glaube, wir haben es tatsächlich mit zwei goldenen Spielern zu tun. Mit Nathaniel Braun und Can Uson, die wirklich überdurchschnittlich gut sind. Ob das Ganze nachhaltig ist? Es wirkt im Moment so. Seit Michael Wiesinger das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum in Nürnberg leitet, sieht das ganz gut aus. Andererseits ist es ja jeder Verein behauptet immer, er will mehr auf den Nachwuchs setzen. In Nürnberg ist es auch eine Frage der Finanzen gewesen, dass man sehen musste, dass viel mehr bleibt uns nicht mehr übrig. Wir können jetzt auch nicht mehr die großen Geldbeträge für andere Spieler ausgeben. Ich würde noch nicht sagen, dass das jetzt ein eindeutiger Trend ist, sondern dass Can Uson und Nathaniel Braun tatsächlich so gut sind, dass man nicht an ihnen vorbei kam.
Die zweite Frage schließt an das, was ich Nando auch schon gefragt habe. Du hast es ein bisschen einfacher. Weil ich ihn gefragt habe, wer von Sportvorstand und Trainer noch da sein wird. Du hast schon eine 100%-Quote, zumindest bei einer Hälfte davon. Das heißt, es bezieht sich noch auf den Trainer. Was wird im Sommer passieren?
Das hängt natürlich vom neuen Vorstand der neuen Vorständin ab. Ich würde sagen, Christian Fjell fährt immer noch von dieser guten Anfangsphase in der Saison. Vielleicht, weil der oder die Neue auch weiß, dass man in Nürnberg im Oktober auch immer noch Trainer entlassen kann. Also ich glaube tatsächlich, dass das erst mal so weitergeht mit Christian Fjell.
Wenn er nicht zu härter wechselt. Aber da werden ja eigentlich alle gerade gehandelt. Du sprichst mit dem Optimismus eines Club-Fans. Dass du sagst, der Trainer bleibt, weil wir können ihn ja auch im Oktober entlassen. Du bist ja kein Fan, sondern ein journalistischer Begleiter. Aber man merkt dir dein Umfeld wirklich an. Jetzt wollte ich eine Brücke zu Eintracht Braunschweig bauen und habe überlegt, wie der Saisonstart von Eintracht Braunschweig war. Es war aber das Gegenteil vom Club. Die Serie kam ja erst später. Aber Anna, es sah ja schon mal kritischer aus für die Eintracht. Hätte man jetzt nicht 3 zu 3 gespielt bei Fürth, dann könnten wir in einer ganz anderen Stimmung miteinander reden. Denn Braunschweig hat 3 Punkte Vorsprung auf Wien-Wiesbaden. Und 6 Punkte sind ja noch auszuspielen. Vielleicht mal einsteigend mit diesem Spiel in Fürth. Was war da los, dass man diese Führung noch verspielt hat? Ich bin irgendwann gar nicht mehr mitgekommen mit dem Wegwischen der Notifications, was da alles passiert ist in dem Spiel.
Ja, zur Chronologie. Wir haben früh 2 Tore gemacht, aus dem Spiel heraus. Schön in so einer Gegenbewegung uns den Ball geschnappt, nach vorne gelaufen, schöne Konter ausgespielt, erfolgreich auch. Sind dann 2-0 in Führung gegangen. Ich glaube, alle in Braunschweig, die es mit der Eintracht halten, hatten bei 2-0 Führung wesentlich mehr Angst als beim Stand von 0-0. Wie du es gerade so schön gesagt hast, der Optimismus eines Clubfans haftet in Art verwandt auch den meisten, zumindest in Braunschweig an. Vor allem, weil wir alle im Kopf hatten, dass eine Woche zuvor die Fürther in Wiesbaden gespielt haben. Also ähnliches Tabellensegment, ähnliche Konkurrenzsituation. Wiesbaden geht 2-0 in Führung. Am Ende hast du wahrscheinlich auch da viele Notifications gewischt. Gewinnt Fürth das Spiel 5-3. Und wir führen 2-0. Und ich hab gedacht, ach du jee. Vor allem kam dazu, ich hatte die ersten zwei Tore verpasst. Hab dann erst später eingeschaltet. Lag vor dem Fernseher und hab gesagt, wenn die jetzt ein Tor machen, die Fürther, dann geh ich wieder raus, schau den Rest des Spiels nicht. So kannst du nicht. Ich bin das Spiel ausgehalten, gerade so. Ja, weil wir am liebsten Fußball spielen ohne den Ball. Ich finde tatsächlich, dass die letzten beiden Spiele, eben gerade haben wir auch kurz das Spiel gegen den HSV touchiert. Das ging nicht so gut aus für uns. Heimniederlage, 4 Gegentore gefangen HSV, Gewinn 4 zu 0 im Eintrachtstadion. Da sind wir mit einem für unsere Verhältnisse ganz guten Ballbesitz von 40% ins Reingegangen, was einfach überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Die Mannschaft kann einfach mit dem Ball nichts wirklich konstruktiv anfangen.
Das heißt, 40% ist schon zu viel Ballbesitz?
Ja, in Fürth haben wir guten Fußball gespielt mit 30% Ballbesitz. Ich würde sagen, das ist genau der Fußball, den die Eintracht im Moment spielen kann und sollte. Je mehr Ballbesitz wir haben, desto schlechter geht es für uns aus. Interessanterweise erinnert das alles an ferne Zeiten, nämlich damals noch unter Lieberknecht. Am erfolgreichsten funktioniert einfach Konterfußball. Der muss so gut sein, dass er auch dann erfolgreich ist, wenn der Gegner sich darauf einstellen kann. Wenn wir Stürmer haben, die in einer guten Tagesform sind, wie Sie es jetzt in Fürth waren, mit Rion Philipp, funktioniert das gut. Kann natürlich auch daneben gehen. Ich glaube, wir hatten 4 Torschüsse und 3 Tore. Das ist natürlich eine Frequenz, die beneidenswert ist. Auch nicht bei jedem Spiel funktioniert. Auf jeden Fall Fürth hat den Ball, kreist uns nach und nach ein. So stabil bestehen wir dann in der Summe eben nicht, dass wir dagegen auch eine Mannschaft, die gerade diese Selbstbewusstsein gewonnen hat, aus der Woche zuvor, sie können diese Spiele spielen, sie können diese Spiele aufholen. Dann fallen die Tore zum einen, dann kriegen wir kurz vor der Pause noch einen Platzverweis. Oben Krause fliegt mit glatt rot vom Platz, ist ein Spieler, über den ich kurz vor diesem Platzverweis noch gesagt habe, das ist eine spannende Personalie, denn man muss sich darauf einstellen, dass er viel falsch macht, und trotzdem ist er wichtig für unser Spiel. Ja, genau, und am Ende spielen wir dann zu 10, liegen 3-2 hinten, machen dann tatsächlich noch den Ausgleich, und kurz vor Schluss hält Rundturm-Hoffmann noch einen Elfmeter, der mit Sicherheit das 4-3 und damit auch den Endstand bedeutet hätte, so geht das Spiel 3-3 aus, und wir waren alle über die Maßen glücklich, möchte ich sagen.
Immerhin noch einen Punkt mitbekommen, und vor allem eben dadurch, dass eben gleichzeitig Kiel gegen Wien-Wiesbaden knapp, zwar, aber gewonnen hat, sind es eben diese drei Punkte Vorsprung. Und du hast ja jetzt schon einiges über Braunschweig erzählt, also bei Besitz nicht so gerne. Ich bin sehr gespannt jetzt aufs Heimspiel gegen Wiesbaden aus.
Hab ich mir tatsächlich notiert.
Schwierig. Ja, vor allem, wenn du das hier so öffentlich erzählst, jetzt wissen die das. Das ist natürlich...
Ja, Max, wie dumm von mir, hier zuzusagen. Ich habe diese Folge und damit auch gerade kurz mein Hände winken, als du gesagt hast, naja, der Club wird ja nicht absteigen. Ich habe dieser Aufnahme zugestimmt unter der Prämisse, dass ich hier nicht über den Nichtabstieg reden muss. Weil das ist gefährlich. Das jinxed.
Die doppelte Verneinung hat mich gerade ein bisschen... Ja, wir wollen das nicht jinxen, das ist schon klar. Aber was ich ja interessant finde, ist, Ballbesitz nicht, aber Verteidigung eigentlich ja. Also diese drei Gegentreffer gegen Fürth, das ist ja untypisch für Eintracht Braunschweig. Die Eintracht hat die acht beste Defensive der Liga. Was kann der Club von Eintracht Braunschweig lernen?
Na, das wäre jetzt so ein bisschen gegenteilig zu nehmen, was Fadi eben gesagt hat, weil das, wovon wir natürlich sehr profitieren, ist immer noch der Trainerwechsel. Auch da, finde ich, geben wir uns in vielem die Hand, denn wir haben mit punktuellen Verstärkungen im Winter dafür gesorgt, dass der Kader endlich dem Trainer steht. Das war vorher einfach ein Problem. Wir sind zum einen in der Gesamtbilanz, stehen wir mit unserer Defensive nicht so schlecht da. Vor allem haben wir nur auf die Rückrunde geschaut, lediglich 17 Gegentore gefangen, was richtig wenig ist. Gerade, wenn man sich die Anfälligkeit bei Standard-Situationen und Hecken anschaut. Und dann eben so Pleiten wie gegen den HSV, die da ja schon inkludiert sind. Grundsätzlich neigen wir nicht dazu, Packungen zu bekommen, zumindest nicht mehr. Diese Statistik, also auch Rückrundentabelle 7, Nano hatte das vorhin auch gesagt, wir haben uns da richtig rausgekämpft. Und vielleicht ist das auch so ein bisschen das, womit zum Beispiel Hertha BSC in der ersten Halbzeit in Braunschweig so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten hatte, die halt auftreten, wie hier, wir sind der Hauptstadtclub und ihr seid Vorletzter. Das waren wir auch irgendwie. Aber tatsächlich stehen wir so schlecht da in der Summe, weil wir eben eine desaströse Anfangsphase immer noch kompensieren und kompensieren müssen. Und dass wir überhaupt jetzt die Chance haben, die Klasse zu halten, habe ich im Oktober nicht gedacht, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Sich da rauszuwühlen, sukzessive unter Scherning einen Platz nach dem anderen ganz langsam und nachhaltig gut zu machen, finde ich phänomenal. Und hängt, Stichwort Defensive, wirklich mit einem Transfer zusammen, den ich unterschätzt habe, nämlich Armin B. Kacic, lange in Hoffenheim gespielt, war vereinslos. Dessen Herz hängt, warum auch immer. Also ich verstehe es natürlich, ihr vielleicht weniger an der Eintracht. Und der ist im Winter zu uns zurückgekommen. Und der schußt da das hinten alles zusammen. Sein Innenverteidiger-Kollege Hasan Kurocay hat einen krassen Sprung gemacht. Der ist im ersten Spiel mit einem Platzverweis direkt rausgegangen im ersten Saisonspiel. Und ich habe gedacht, aiaiai. Der hat sich brutal entwickelt und das in einem Dreieck mit einem wirklich sehr guten Torhüter, Ron-Tom Hoffmann, der von Bayern 2 kam, rettet uns da hinten. Hoffentlich, hoffentlich auch noch die nächsten beiden Spiele.
Ja, also Eisen Arnim ist schon mehrfach hier in den Braunschweig-Segmenten mit dir gefallen. Aber das ist schon wirklich erstaunlich. Wir haben einen ähnlichen Effekt, finde ich, gibt es mit... Wer ist der, der zu Hannover gegangen ist? Heißtenberg oder Klostermann? Ah ja, der Heißtenmann. Es ist mit dieser Fehler auch passiert. Aber da haben wir es auch schon, dass quasi ein Spieler kommt und so deutlich besser ist als alle anderen, dass er a. nicht in Probleme gerät, in Situationen, in denen Zweitligaspieler in der Regel in Probleme geraten. Und als zweites dann aber auch noch all seine Mitspieler in der direkten Umgebung besser macht. Und das scheint ja bei Bitschak zu 100% genauso zu sein.
Definitiv. Also ich hab sogar das Gefühl, dass Kurochai so ein kleiner Ermin-Klon wird. So von der Körpersprache her und so. Er macht das so souverän. Auch die Selbstbewusstsein bei den Strafstößen, die er für uns verwandelt hat. Wirklich phänomenal, richtig großartige Entwicklung. Wie gesagt, ich habe nicht gedacht, dass wir hier stehen würden. Ich war gerade total überrascht, als ich Fadi über die Perspektive der Clubberer habe reden hören. Weil ich mich mit Nürnberg nicht wirklich beschäftigt habe im Sinne von Konkurrenz, Abstiegskonkurrenz. Da sehe ich tatsächlich immer noch eher Kaiserslautern. In diesem typischen lauterer Größenwahn, der ihnen dann und wann schon das Genick gebrochen hat. Ich wünsche ihnen jetzt persönlich nichts Schlechtes, aber natürlich möchte ich eher die Liga halten. Und jetzt geht es wirklich in die Crunch-Time. Wir spielen gegen Wien-Wiesbaden und dann am letzten Spieltag auf dem Betzenberg. Das ist natürlich die Hölle. Und wir sollten alles in unserer Macht stehende dafür tun, dass wir da einfach betrunken hinfahren können. Weil alles egal ist. Ja, ja, genau. Also ich bin verhalten optimistisch. Wiesbaden ist genau gegenläufig. Die haben sehr gut angefangen und befinden sich auf dem tendenziell absteigenden, zumindest im Trend, im gesamten Trend absteigenden, auf dem absteigenden Ast. Und dann eben diese vielleicht nicht 100% verdiente, aber stattgefundene Niederlage gegen nicht besonders starke Kieler. Und dann davor eben 2-0 führen und dann 5-3 verlieren gegen Fürth. Ich glaube, da haben wir einen leichten psychologischen Vorteil. Problem, wir spielen zu Hause gegen die direkte Konkurrenz und müssen was mit dem Ball anfangen. Das ist halt im Fußball wirklich ein schwieriges Thema, wenn du halt mit dem Ball nichts machen kannst.
Ja, dass beim Fußball der Ball so eine große Rolle spielt.
Ja, das ist einfach ärgerlich. Das ist wirklich ein notwendiges Detail. Vielleicht ein bisschen außer Acht gelassen zuletzt.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es nicht eigentlich auch eine Stärke der Eintracht in dem Jahr gewesen, dass man gegen Teams, die hinter einem standen, also jetzt, gut, man stand natürlich so weit hinten, dass es nicht so viele Teams gab, die hinter einem standen. Aber du meinst, also quasi gegen die, die jetzt auch hinter und rund um Eintracht Braunschweig stehen, gegen die habt ihr doch eigentlich eine ganz gute Bilanz. In der Hinserie ja auch zwei Siege gegen Wien, Wiesbaden und Lautern.
Also wir haben gegen Wiesbaden gewonnen, wir haben gegen Lautern zu Hause gewonnen, was uns nicht so oft gelungen ist. Und dann in einer Phase, in der auch Magdeburg da unten durchaus noch eine Rolle gespielt hat, haben wir auch gegen Magdeburg gewonnen. Das heißt, ja, tatsächlich, das auf der einen Seite, einen richtig großen Sprung, und den haben wir damals nicht gemacht, war zu Hause das Spiel gegen Rostock, das haben wir verloren. Und war vielleicht auch keine starke Phase, vielleicht so das größte Down der Saison und unter dem aktuellen Trainer. Ich hoffe, dass die Phase im Moment eine andere ist. So richtig viele Siege hatten wir zuletzt halt auch nicht. Gegen Osnabrück, da hätte ich gerne noch höher gewonnen. Auch weil das Torverhältnis einfach noch wirklich wichtig werden kann. Und dann spielst du zu Hause gegen den HSV, lässt dir dafür Dinge einschenken. Gegen Glatzel, der sich nicht mal freut. Was ist ein Problem vom HSV, dass sie sich nicht über ihre Tore freuen?
Doch wir haben uns gefreut.
Also später hat er mal auch sein Wappen gezeigt. Das hat er glaube ich noch nicht gemacht.
Gegen Pauli muss man das tun.
Ja, aber natürlich interessanter Hinweis, also so gut die Abwehr von Braunschweig ist, die von Wien-Wiesbaden ist noch ein Treffer besser. Und deswegen steht er tatsächlich gerade bei der identischen Tordifferenz. Und das könnte wirklich noch relevant werden. Auf der anderen Seite, ich will jetzt auch hier natürlich nichts jinxen, aber wenn ich mir zum Beispiel allein die Situation von Kaiserslautern angucke. Die sind vier Punkte vor, die spielen jetzt als nächstes bei der Hertha. Was haben sie bei der Hertha geschafft? Die sind im DFB-Pokal weitergekommen. Und die können da den Nichtabstieg klar machen. Und dann wissen wir doch, wie dieses Heimspiel laufen wird gegen Eintracht Braunschweig. Dann sind die im Kopf beim DFB-Pokalfinale und könnten ja sowieso das Witzigste überhaupt machen. Wenn sich jetzt alle in der 1. Liga um den 8. Platz ketschen und dann wird Lautern Pokalsieger und der 8. Platz, reicht für gar nichts mehr.
Ja, ja, das stimmt. Wir haben auf dem Betzenberg nie besonders geglänzt. Ich glaube, das haben auch die wenigsten getan. Die größte Chance ist wahrscheinlich wirklich das Heimspiel jetzt gegen Wiesbaden am Sonntag. Das wäre wirklich, wirklich gut. Ja, und würde mich auch einfach sehr freuen, weil ich finde, dass der Verein viele gute Sachen im Moment macht. In den letzten sechs Monaten viele gute Entscheidungen getroffen hat. Ich empfinde die Stimmung im Moment als positiv, als konstruktiv, als nach vorne gewandt. Und zwar ohne dieses, hey, wann steigen wir wieder auf? Sondern du hast halt im Braunschweig einfach Bock auf 2. Liga, ins Eintracht-Stadion gehen, Hannover 96 endlich mal wieder schlagen, sowas. Also gar nicht irgendwie die großen Sprünge. Und ich glaube, diese Genügsamkeit ist im Moment ein total nachhafter Boden für eine Fußball-Fan-untypische Zufriedenheit mit dem eigenen Verein. Und das würde mich einfach kolossal freuen für Benny Kessel, auch für Marc Pfitzner, der ja wirklich am Tiefpunkt aller blau-gelben Seelen letzten Herbst diese beiden Spiele geleitet hat, wenn das klappen würde.
Ach, Anna, und man merkt doch einfach, was für ein gottverdammter Podcast-Profi du bist, indem du Hannover 96 erwähnt und gleichzeitig dissed, indem du sagst, naja, Hannover 96 besiegen, also gar nicht so große Sprünge. Wie schlau, ihm einfach so noch einen mitzugeben. Ach, einfach gut. Aber auf einer Skala von 0 bis 100, wie ätzend ist es, dass der vorletzte Spieltag nicht mehr zeitgleich stattfindet? Denn es gibt ja auch, ich meine, für euch ist es von Vorteil, aber es gibt ja ein Szenario, dass Hansa Rostock auf Schalke keine Punkte holt. Und damit wäre ja der direkte Abstieg schon gar nicht mehr möglich für Eintracht Braunschweig. Also es ist in dem Fall jetzt für euch gut, aber irgendwie fühlt sich das falsch an. Wir alle wissen, warum es so ist, wegen Geld natürlich. Aber schade.
Das wäre schon geil, auch Bundesliga. Ich meine, irgendwie ist da ja der größte Drops auch schon gelutscht. Aber mehr Bock macht es schon, wenn es einfach parallel alles stattfindet.
Ich würde deswegen ganz gerne mit euch allen drei noch mal kurz auf das Restprogramm im Tabellenkeller blicken. Weil in der Tabellenspitze haben wir es vorhin mit Düsseldorf und dem HSV eigentlich schon ausführlich besprochen. Mehr kann da jetzt auch nicht mehr passieren. So ist das halt. Aber im Tabellenkeller. Also Schalke können wir, die führen immer noch 2 zu 0, haben mehrere Chancen aufs 3 zu 0 vergeben, wenn der Ticker der Sportshow hier richtig ist. Die können wir rauslassen. Dann haben wir eben Nürnberg zu Hause gegen Elbersberg, dann beim HSV, Lautern in Hertha, dann zu Hause gegen Eintracht Braunschweig. Braunschweig logischerweise jetzt gegen Wien-Wiesbaden und dann in Lautern wie in Wiesbaden logischerweise gegen Braunschweig und gegen St. Pauli dann. Und Hansel Rostock müssen wir noch mit reinnehmen. Die spielen dann eben auf Schalke und dann zu Hause gegen Paderborn. Fadi, du das mal beginnen. Wann macht der Club fertig? Oder wird man jetzt wirklich gegen Elbersberg zu Hause auch verlieren?
Ich hätte einfach gerne, dass einer von euch dreien mir jetzt vorrechnet, dass der Club trotz zweier Niederlagen sowieso überhaupt nicht mehr absteigen kann. Damit bist du immer in meinem Herzen. Ich nehme diese St. Pauli HSV-Peinlichkeit wieder zurück hier mit. Das war eine super Aktion von beiden Seiten. Oder nicht nur vom HSV. St. Pauli sind die Bösen.
Ich kann es auch wirklich erklären, weil ich auch vorhin meinte, ich freue mich, dass Lautern in der ersten Liga bleibt, weil ich einfach davon ausgehe, Braunschweig gewinnt ihr Heimspiel. Und Rostock holt keine drei Punkte, und dann ist das Thema durch. Und dann ist es egal, wie Nürnberg spielt, wie Lautern spielt, dann kommt da Wiesbaden nicht mehr hoch. Der 34. Spieltag könnte gar nicht mehr im Abstiegskampf interessant sein. Ich habe da großes Vertrauen im Braunschweig. Ich persönlich. Ich glaube nicht, dass Rostock irgendwie noch die fehlenden Punkte holt, auch nicht bei ihrer Tor-Differenz. Und dann ist das Thema eigentlich am Wochenende auch im Abstiegskampf gegessen. Deswegen war meine Aussage nicht gegen Braunschweig anders, sondern eher, weil ich glaube, dass das Thema für Lautern auch durch ist, weil da unten Wiesbaden irgendwie nicht mehr rauskommen wird.
Alles klar, dann betrink ich mich jetzt.
Du kannst auch gerne betrunken nach Kaiserslautern fahren. Du musst eingelernen.
Kommt ihr an Nürnberg vorbei?
Ja, wir können sie nicht schlenken machen. Wir müssen uns nur einigen, ob Wein oder Bier. Alles klar, Wein, gerne.
Als jemand, der mal ein 0 zu 0 von Lautern gegen Union auf dem Betzenberg gesehen hat, kann ich sowieso empfehlen, da nur Betrunken hinzufahren.
Das habe ich jetzt schon von mehreren gehört.
Es gibt da gute Weinschorle, deshalb ja.
Ich meine, ich wollte schon das Gegenargument einführen, aber es ist doch am letzten Spieltag immer noch spannend. Aber wäre es ja noch zwischen Wiesbaden und Rostock, also dann, während die Relegation kommt, das wäre die Spannung. Also sprich, wir sind uns alle einig, ihr seid alle gerettet und der HSV steigt vielleicht noch auf.
Bitte nicht.
Nicht solche Hoffnung. Das wäre doch die Pointe für all die HSV-Saisons, als der Jäger oder der Gejagte es nicht geschafft hat. Und jetzt eben dann einmal hat man halt selber so einen Slip irgendwie in der 104. Spielminute dann durch einen Strafstoß, der vielleicht nicht so ganz eindeutig ist. Und dann Relegation gegen den Erstleagisten. Was soll schiefgehen?
Ja klar, also das wäre natürlich die Hollywood-Geschichte schlechthin, wenn das Ganze sich jetzt am letzten Spieltag komplett drehen würde für den HSV und du dann auch noch die Relegation überstehst. Aber darüber will ich wirklich nicht nachdenken, weil das macht nur irgendwie ein ungutes Gefühl. Und dann sitzt man hier am Freitag und dann reicht es nicht gegen Paderborn.
Und dann nee, nee, nee.
Das ist zu, zu...
Ich traue euch das absolut zu nach der Stunde jetzt. Wenn es einer schafft, in die erste Liga aufzusteigen, dann der HSV.
Das muss man jetzt aber auch sagen, wie euphorie-trunken du bist, seitdem dir Nandu gesagt hat, dass der Club nicht abbleibt.
Wirklich. Ich nehme Urlaub und fahre nach Kaiserslautern mit Braunschweig und so. Alles cool.
Es ist so wunderschön, hier zu sein.
Wir sehen uns nächstes Jahr alle wieder.
Das ist doch super. Ich würde mich darüber freuen. So eine Runde wie mit euch, die moderiert sich wie von alleine. Auch wenn ich einschränkend sagen muss, ob jetzt ein Aufstieg des HSV wirklich Hollywood-reif wäre oder ob es dann nicht doch vielleicht nur für die Bavaria-Filmstudies hier von meiner Hausruhe reicht, das würde ich mal noch zur Diskussion stellen.
Ich würde mir auf jeden Fall persönlich auch wünschen, da würde ich mich dann nur anschließen, dass der Kandidat aus Rostock den Weg runter antritt.
Dazu habe ich im hinrunden Rückblick ausführlich geäußert. Wobei da ja wieder ganz andere Themen dranhängen, weil wenn die Vereine dann aus der Sichtbarkeit verschwinden, passieren noch schlimmere Dinge. Schaut euch an, was jetzt bei Aachen so passiert ist, als sie mal ein bisschen aus dem Licht der Öffentlichkeit weg wären. Glückwunsch zum Aufstieg. Aber Leute, ihr habt Hausaufgaben. Das ist nochmal was Eigenes. Aber gut, im Grunde müssen wir jetzt die letzten Spieltage gar nicht mehr abwarten. Wir haben es hier ausführlich besprochen, wie es laufen wird. Ich freue mich auch, dass wir hier mit so guter Laune rausgehen. Anna, du musstest auch gar nichts jinxen. Das haben wir alle anderen für dich übernommen.
Nanu übernimmt die mathematische Verantwortung. Sehr gerne. Ich habe total Bock auf die nächste Zweitligasaison. Die Aufsteiger aus der 3. Liga sehen gut aus. Die Kandidaten aus der Bundesliga bringen noch mehr Publikum runter. Dann wollen wir mal sehen, über was wir uns so unterhalten an Sensationen, wenn wir zum Ausgang Kiel gegen Heidenheim gucken.
Ja, das ist aber jetzt noch ein ganz anderes Thema. Schön, dass du jetzt mir noch mal einen reingewirkt hast. Aber gut, so verteilt es sich fair unter allen. Ihr drei, es war eine wunderschöne Runde. Fadi Keblavi, Nando Silva, Anna Lautenbach. Ich werde natürlich verlinken, wo man euch alle hören und wo man euch folgen kann. Es sei auch allen Hörern und Hörerinnen sehr ans Herz gelegt. Danke euch dreien, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt für den Rasenfunk. Und euch lieben Hörern und Hörern danke ich natürlich für eure Unterstützung, denn der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt pale wall werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Und in dieser Folge danke ich Blutin Olli, Don Bratwurst1848, Maxi, Stefan K., Krokodok, Igor P und Les Ink. Sie alle haben uns nicht nur unterstützt auf rasenfunk.de slash-supportersclub, sondern sie haben sich dort auch registriert als SupporterInnen. Und dementsprechend konnte ich ihnen hier danken. Ihr könnt uns auch auf kiosk.rasenfunk.de den letzten Merch noch wegkaufen und uns so unterstützen. Und ihr könnt uns sehr gerne weiterempfehlen. Das wäre auch so schön. Schöne zwei Spieltage euch allen noch. Bleibt gesund, bis bald. Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.